all right and welcome to the premiere
episode of chess openings explained in
this series we're going to be going over
some different openings a variety of
openings so sometimes there'll be more
strategical openings sometimes they'll
be more tactical openings today I chose
one that's kind of in the middle it's
very strategically complex and there's a
lot of tactics that both players should
be aware of so we're going to go over
the the typical plans for both sides in
the opening I chose today is the note
Blum also I guess I guess I should let
you know I'm Jonathan Schantz I'll be
doing the lecture tonight so the note
Blum is one of my my favorite openings
so I chose it so the note Blum occurs in
the semis slav and there's a variety of
ways that you can reach it in the
opening but we'll just go ahead and put
it on the board so that we can see it
and so in this position we've made a
triangle as as black and here so on one
move would be to enter the the semi Slav
which would be a completely different
opening class also you can set up the
stonewall by the play in f5 and you set
up the the Stonewall structure with your
pawns like this or you can play the note
Blum which is to take on c4 so when you
play this way
it's a you're going to try to keep your
pawn and you're going to make white work
as hard as you can to get it back of
course this is advantageous to white in
a certain sense because he will get the
center and as we we see he'll get some
certain advantages that we'll go over a
quick move about move orders there's
there's several different ways that this
can occur I mean you can play a six is
probably the most common way and then
white can begin with either Knight this
one is typical and I've chosen to go
this way first because it should be
known that white is allowed this
particular move when you when this move
order
on there which would enter the Marshall
gambit which is outside of the realm
outside of the scope of this lecture but
we'll look at it just briefly so you can
get an idea to decide if you'd want to
play this way so if you take Knight
takes the gambit line begins with this
check now in the World Championship
Magnus Carlsen just retreated his knight
which isn't anything special for white
but it's okay it's a way to play and the
only time I've had this position against
a higher rated player in a tournament he
chose Knight c3 and that game resulted
in a draw but uh okay the gambit line is
to play Bishop d2 your your attacking
the bishop and so we win upon as black
and when you take back we take the
knight so you're up upon but this line
is very very dangerous it is
it's too dangerous to grab this Jeep on
it's just well known that Bishop f3 is
kind of bad news for black he's he's
making too many Queen moves and just in
my my personal opinion having played the
black side of this a few times I think
it's it's pretty good for white it's the
kind of thing where black needs to know
a lot of theory just to kind of survive
the opening things can get really
dangerous we're not going to go into it
too much today but it's worth knowing
that this this is something that can
happen and I kind of try to stay away
from it as black but okay it's something
that you should know about if this is to
come up in any of your games so now
we're going to go over a few different
games first I'm going to show you an
entertaining game just to warm you up to
see what this looks like in a real game
and we'll get sort of to the the
starting point see what it's it's like
when we look a little bit more in depth
in this position okay so we see a
queen's gambit declined move order and
now we've set up the triangle so instead
of playing e4 common is Knight f3 and we
take on c4 this is our our big point now
in the game a 4 was played ok which is
the normal way to continue this he's
trying to make it difficult for black to
play the move B 5 because that's blacks
plan is he played C 6 he's going to play
B 5 he's going to protect his pawn and
then he's going to try to hold on to it
for as long as possible to make it
difficult for for white and he's going
to try to say in the long run I'm gonna
be up upon in most end games that's
going to be great for me so white has to
make it tough so so a 4 and now here's
one of the points we pin the knight
which is going to help us fight for
control over b5 because at the moment if
it was blacks turn again he could play
the move b5 and there wouldn't be any
threat to take twice there because the
knight is in a pin okay so III which is
the most common move sometimes white
plays it plays a gambit with g3 sorry g3
alright with g3 also e4 is not thought
of to be the the best because okay at
some point
this move is is going to win a tempo on
the pandu to the pin but it's very very
playable so it's it's a line worth
knowing but we're going to focus on the
main line today because there's there's
a lot going on in the main line okay so
white intends to get the pawn back and
so now black can play b5 so there's
there's no real threat or yet to take
here because we can just take back the
night is in a pin so let's see so we can
play another move for a white here so
white breaks the pin and now again he's
threatening to take on b5 so the move
here might be surprising if you haven't
seen this opening before black is
actually going to give back the pawn and
in exchange he's going to get two
passers on the on the King side on the
Queen side so we'll take a look in this
game the slightly different move order
was played the most common move here is
a5 which can be surprising if you
haven't seen it before but the
we'll be revealed after white takes here
so if we take back we lose upon
immediately so black needs to take the
night first now the bishop will take its
it's kind of pointless to take with with
the pawn now this this bishop is a he's
not looking too good on on d2 and it's
you know this will be kind of easy for
for black to eventually make be for work
so okay they'll almost always take with
a bishop and when you take back it looks
like you know you could you're doing
good but why it can undermine your your
queen side play with a move like b3 now
if you were able to make this move work
this would be a fantastic opening and
everybody would play it as black if this
was the kind of thing that happened well
now you just be crushing white
strategically these guys are just so
strong they make a very good impression
and this the bishop on c1 really is
doing nothing but this does not work
tactically so is there anyone in this
very intelligent audience that can tell
me what white would play here instead of
just retreating the bishop all right
yeah Bishop takes b4 exploiting thank
you exploiting the fact that there's a
pan along the a file so okay so you
cannot play this move yet so black will
typically you know put his Bishop on b7
and now when white takes back we're
going to push so we've created two
passers on the Queen side which is
something you don't see in any other
opening and in return okay white will
stay on on this diagonal where he'll
he'll have a lot of pressure and he'll
play for a King side attack in the
future Wade does have a lot to to be you
know impressed with he he has a big
control of the center he's going to try
to make moves like efore work in the
future and build a really big center and
usually you
either when in the center or play for
checkmate against the king so in general
if you you don't get checkmate it as
black you're going to be doing really
well in the endgame because your plan is
really easy and obvious you just you
push these guys you just keep pushing
and you try to make Queens so that plan
is obvious most of the strategies in
this opening revolve around what white
does black will almost always be doing
the same thing he's trying to push his
Queen side passers so we'll we'll take a
look we'll go back to our our game
alright so we'll see how they arrive to
it in a this game where the slightly
unusual Bishop d7 was played more common
as a 5 so after takes we can't take back
on b5 so we take the knight after they
take back now now we can take back okay
so b3 was played and now a5 was played
so we've reached the position we saw
just a moment ago and we're going to
check out this game so we're going to
start from this position which isn't
quite the starting position or the
normal tabia where the main main line
begins but it's it is where we can start
to see the the clear plans and just a
spoiler alert about this game
both of these pawns are going to become
Queen's and at some point white is going
to have three pawns past pawns on the
seventh rank so it's going to be a very
entertaining game which is why I've
chosen to show this first because in
opening like this that's so complex it
can lead to some some really artistic
games some really beautiful games so
we'll look at this one first okay
now mostly players will just develop
their pieces and castles which means
okay so the Knights going to go to f6
the other knights coming here not
blocking in the bishop and he's trying
to control these key squares and he's
going to castle and then decide where to
put his Queen in this rook what is going
to develop its Bishop and castle so
that's what we're going to see now
there's not
huge difference here from a three-hour
etiquette of view if you are Castle
first or you play Knight B to d7 they're
almost always reach the the same
position now most common here is both
players to Castle but we can we can
understand okay both players will Castle
will reach this position and this is
sort of the starting position that we're
going to look at today so there's
basically three plans three different
moves that white can try in this
position which is what you need to know
if you're playing this as either side so
a move not the most common move but a
move is Queen c2 which is what we're
going to look at in this game and it's
it's not meant to be the the most
testing move according to modern theory
so it's will spend only a little bit of
time on it the most popular move is rook
to e1 so we'll spend some time looking
at that the point is you just want to
play the movie four and play in the
center and another move is Knight to d2
and we'll we'll check out the point of
this move with the strange night retreat
what's that all about we'll look at that
in another game so okay in this game
we're looking at the Queen c2 line where
both players have castled and whenever
as a general rule when the queen is on
c2 black almost always puts the Queen on
c7 there's some lines especially in the
the rook e1 lines that we'll look at a
little bit later where the Queen does
not want to go to c7 but okay when the
Queen's here the Queen normally goes to
c7 and now white likes to push in the
center so this was the point of his move
Queen c2 he was controlling e4 and so he
got to to push now black should stop
white from playing e5 if you play e5
you're you're going to be really cramped
and you're going to get into a lot of
trouble so black has to play the move e5
himself so there's there's a couple
things you can do whenever you have this
situation where there's some tension in
the center you can push you can capture
or you can ignore
those are your three options two of them
are very strategically
you know ill-advised in this position d5
is a huge positional mistake it gives up
the very important c5 square this is the
dream square for the night because it'll
be really useful in assisting all of his
pawns to advance in the future so if
you're ever allowed to put your knight
here uncontested you're going to be in
really good business so it doesn't have
to go there immediately we can focus on
protecting our a pawn first or whatever
but when we get our Knight there we're
going to be be really thrilled which is
the same sort of thing that will happen
if they take again they've they've given
us the c5 square so our Knight will go
there in the near future and okay this
knight can do two things it can you know
just go here and recuperate the pond or
it can even try to play for an attack
and maneuver its way to f4 so you have
some options but a the big problem is if
you give up the c5 square you're gonna
be in bad shape as white you know you
you're already going to be worse for a
long long time in this game so whites
move might be a surprise if you haven't
played these positions much but it's a
the move
c5 so by putting the pawn on c5 now the
knight can immediately go there
so when black takes back to kind of ruin
the center this pawn is isolated but
there are a lot of tactical threats that
can happen immediately because we are
thinking about making a move like c6 for
example if we played just a terrible
move for for black so somehow we'll get
my give ourselves a move okay if we just
get to play this move sometimes there's
there's a lot of tactical tricks
I guess not here the Queen just takes
but we'll look at a when these tricks
work and when they don't so here we
should defend our pawn one more time so
that's what was played and in the future
one
the points of playing this move is to
maneuver the night to b5 where you will
be threatening to play the move c6 and
you're working to blockade you can put
the bishop back on a4 at some moment and
you're going to be blockading which is
going to be a huge theme in this opening
white is going to try to blockade the
Queen side pawns and then black is going
to fight to fight against the blockade
which is going to be be important so
we'll see a lot of that today okay so in
this game
black realizes okay this might be coming
which is is usually a really good move
when he gets it in especially because
then when this this Knight has to move
somewhere we'd be taking on on h7 so mm
okay so black decides to fight for
control of the e5 square okay which
makes makes a lot of sense and now
Bishop b5 which comes with the threat of
c6 and it's focusing on the a4 square
which is going to be important for for a
blockade okay
so black gets his is Knight out of the
way now if c6 there's there's no Forks
and we have it defended enough times now
okay and we might be thinking about
taking on f3 shattering the pawns so
white trades and by takes back of course
alright and f4
this is the kind of thing white needs to
do something on the King side eventually
these these guys haven't gone anywhere
yet but in the near future they might
get serious about pushing down the board
and so often white has to play for
checkmate so okay so this move makes a
lot of sense
and now the knight has a good square on
c6 okay the bishop is attacked in it it
wants to stay on this diagonal because
it's going to have some some threats
against the King at some point and now
black has to make a very important
choice he can play the move Bishop a6 as
he did in the game
and this is kind of one of the most
important trades in the bloomfeld in the
no bloom sorry is a wind should you
trade the LightSquared bishop s-- it's
often you know very dangerous when
you're black you want to be really
careful is it a good idea to trade
LightSquared bishop s-- because differ
squares you need to push your pawns to
over here are these light squares so you
really need control of the light squares
but here it makes a lot of sense because
with the the trade of the light squared
bishop s-- the night is going to feel a
lot more comfortable on c6 so that's a
pretty good night and you're right and
his his life squared Bishop is doing an
excellent job blockading so we're going
to fight against that by trying to trade
so you can't really avoid the trade you
don't want to give up complete control
of the light squares and take the night
and you don't want to drop the exchange
here you'd be you know what black would
be able to take your your rook so he's
kind of compelled to trade and black
will take back okay so white has to do
something in the game he didn't really
find at a brilliant plan he played the
move Queen e2 which okay which has a
good point to it perhaps the Queen will
come in here and work with the bishop
he's going to attack g7 and try to
provoke some weaknesses from the black
camp so that he can open it up with his
pawns here in the center and he can try
to get at the King play for checkmate
mmm but uh he kind of kind of flounders
in that in the game he doesn't come up
with a good plan or a fast enough attack
all right for the moment the rook is
attacked so black will have to defend it
or move it he defends it with the move
Queen a7 and so okay so we're
threatening to win this this pawn here
and you could try to play move like
queen g4 and sacrifice a pawn with check
and try to make that work but uh okay he
plays the move rook f2 and it's becoming
obvious the white doesn't really have a
truly good plan here all right the pawn
is untouchable of course because the the
rook would be hanging but okay his last
few moves were to put his major pieces
on the second-ranked and meanwhile black
has gotten ready to play the move a
or so black is ready to go through with
his plans which is to push all of his
pawns and white really hasn't made you
know a lot of progress in any King side
attack so okay so a four he gets to push
his pawns and now he's about to play the
move a three and then you'll play b3 the
pawns will just keep rolling down the
board so he's got to make some threats
and that's what he did so the threat is
a queen takes g7 checkmate so there's
there's several different ways so I'll
I'll ask our incredibly intelligent
audience how would you defend as black
in this position any of the millions of
hands out here can go ahead and answer
the question okay the move I was hoping
somebody would say black really wants to
avoid making any weaknesses on the on
the Kings side the point is now we'll be
able to open the position sometime in
the future with moves like you know f5
take on g6 these are the kinds of things
you might want to do he might also want
to get a pawn all the way to f6 and then
weasel the Queen around for a for a well
known mate that I teach all my students
known as lollies mate with the pawn on
f6 and the Queen on hh6 so okay so
instead in the game f5 was preferred so
now the Queen will defend laterally it
does sacrifice a pond but notice what's
more important is who's going to be
first is white gonna checkmate black or
is black going to be able to push his
Queen side pawns get enough counter play
and make Queens so alright let's see a3
you need to save your bishop so he moves
to e5 alright
b3 and the you know these ponds are
becoming really really quick and why it
is in a lot of trouble so he needs to
play an aggressive attacking move so
that's what happened in the game he
played the move f6 he's got to play
something like this but from a objective
standpoint black is just going to be
faster and he should be able to
to win from this position though well
we'll see what the result is in the end
okay the puns ponds are coming fast all
right so he takes and now it would be
you know really insulting to the
audience if I didn't give them credit
for understanding that a to fails
because it blunders mate in 24 obviously
everyone in this this room sees it but
for those few out there that may not
understand why a two is impossible in
this position and it is rather
entertaining how white can win from this
position because it's all right it's
very difficult to see but it's it begins
with this move threatening checkmate
so okay you must take you take the rook
the queen is in the pens you must take
with the king it is very difficult to
see how white is going to be able to not
only survive but win this but we begin
with a nice little chick and there's a
lot of lot of tempting moves if you even
take the rook on a6 the b-pawn is
probably going to Queen which which
might not win for white so okay we play
this check and it's it's tempting to
take the Queen but again after we we
take the Queen and we take here we're
not going to be happy when this happens
so that doesn't quite work yet okay so
we take on a6 with check all right the
King must move again we still don't have
time to play rook takes Queen so we need
to bring the Queen around the other way
so she's gone all around the board
giving checks you have to block we take
now an important move h4 and eventually
what's going to happen is we're going to
be able to take the Queen with check
when we're in a position to check the
King and then take one of the ponds so I
don't know how much of this the player
saw but perhaps black/nude ok a6 was
going to be too dangerous in this
position
so instead the moon Queen f7 was was
played okay so yes so he's trying to
make it hard for white to push his pawns
so you can't play a two yet because the
b-pawn hangs so okay he's trying to make
it work perhaps he's thinking about
pushing the beep on making medic ween so
white defends which surprisingly is is
the losing move even though he doesn't
lose he should at first insert the move
f7 and then he's doing well the first
point is okay you can't take because
you'll you'll end up getting checkmated
and you can use either rook can take on
f8 and it'll be checkmate so I'll leave
it up to you to pick in your own mind
which one you think it's better but uh
coop
but with this movement inserted white
can now defend the back rank and
there'll be some some more problems for
the second player here so what happens
we'll look at why a little bit when we
see what what happens here in a - and
it's funny a - is again it throws away
the win it's now a draw which is kind of
hard to believe because blacks about to
make a bunch of queens but he should
prefer instead a move that I guess it's
kind of hard to see he should put both
of his rooks on the second rank so that
now you can meet this with simply taking
so you've prevented causing you problems
in the game that wasn't played so white
again has a chance to play f7 and this
time he did so the King moved and now
we're going to see you know some very
interesting stuff black's about to make
some queens okay so we might as well
grab the rook while we can so he makes
his first queen so as promised these
pawns are all going to become queens
let's see so white attacks the rook so
somehow the rook needs to be defended
alright and now he pushes he's just
going to play the movie se7en and they
have threats of taking so the Queen was
taken which is fine
takes back another Queen so as promised
all of the the Queen's made it now the
pawns made it they turned into Queens
all right wait attacks the rook black
saves one of the Queen's with check and
then he brings the the other Queen back
to defend against the threat of he takes
f8 so okay so white makes more threats
he's going to make lots of Queens so as
as advertised White has three passed
pawns then which is funny so Black has
two Queens but he has to force a draw
here so he can sacrifice his queen and
force a perpetual there's not all so the
game ended here it was a draw there's a
there's no real way for him to to keep
playing for more
if he ever you know goes to the h-file
we'll just keep checking them back and
forth between the H of the G file if he
ever tries to run this way we'll have
checks and you know you keep running you
know we're going to start taking all
your stuff and then you're not going to
be able to win so okay so that was a
pretty entertaining game I like it now
we'll get to some more much more recent
games that will be more interesting from
a theoretical standpoint so the first
game we're going to go over to is a
really nice game that was played by
Hikaru Nakamura as the black pieces and
he was playing against Jon Ludvig hammer
so this was a pretty pretty good match
and I really like the way black played
in this game every move he played was
perfect until the end when every movie
played became practical so we'll take a
look at it this time the opening was
reached and from a slightly different
move order but we set up the triangle so
now we have it we can play the note
bloom alright alright our average rating
just went up for our attendance was
we're doing pretty good today okay III
was played here instead of a four
there's not a huge difference it's
almost certainly going to transpose all
right so we weep in the night all right
so all of this is normal we've seen this
you have to give up the bishop before
you take back b3 okay so we get this
this position again and then since
they're good players they develop their
pieces and castled and we'll get back to
our starting position that we'd seen
from a moment ago okay so here again is
our position so we looked a little bit
at the move Queen c2 which the point was
just to play e4 and we saw that in our
last game now we're going to look at
yeah the second most common move which
is Knight - D - now why would why would
he play such a mysterious retreat well
one idea a less common idea is just to
play F 3 and E 4 and have a nice Center
but the the more common strategy is to
play for even more than that we'll see
that in the game what's going to play a
move like F for preventing a5 from ever
happening and then he's going to play e4
and have a very nice Center so it's it's
going to be a little bit more
challenging for black than in the
previous game that we that we saw
Nakamura is black yep okay so Queen c7
she'll be useful here especially when
they play 92 you want to play this move
sometimes you're going to have tricks
based on the fact that you know you you
can sometimes make a threat of checkmate
it's also nice that the Queen is
protecting the e5 square so we're almost
ready to play e5 is black but uh okay so
white will normally shut you down play
f4 and now White's ready to play e4 and
the center will be really strong and
he's going to try to push black off the
board okay so the point also of Queen c7
is now in this position you have a very
nice move we want to move our pawns as
quickly as possible so here we can do it
so you might be be a bit confused is
this is the number one American player
just just dropping upon it's only
protected once so can can somebody in
the now very high rated audience tell me
what black would play here what happens
it he just went upon it's blacks turn to
move so right so white just took our
pawn so if we just lose our pond we're
just going to be totally losing because
we gave up our whole Queen side yes
excellent so the move is Queen c6 with a
double threat you're you're going to
threaten checkmate and you're also
threatening the rook so right so that's
the point and this is a tactical trick
that happens all the time a lot of times
black needs to resort to tactics to make
as pawns move forward so that'll be a
very common theme that you'll see a lot
in a lot of these games here so okay so
the pawn cannot be captured and it's
black is about to play the move a3 which
will come with tempo because it's
attacking the bishop so that explained
why white moved his rook over so now if
you play a three you can back your
Bishop up and you know you'll be able to
blockade these are these pawns because
you have a night that will probably come
to be three and then it'll become really
hard for for black to pushes pawns so
this move kind of prevents a three-four
for the moment and now we'll see another
very common idea our Knights want to go
to c5 that's something that all that
will happen in all of these variations
and it will happen even if c5 is
defended so here the rook is eyeballing
the bishop so black is dreaming about
playing the move Knight to c5 for
example if we we pass Knight to c5 with
the point that the Bishop is undefended
so this would this would be horrendous
you wouldn't be able to take the knight
okay so why it should defend the bishop
after rook F to d8 he defends the bishop
he plays Queen e2 and now okay when we
can push our ponds we should so
eventually this rook might take our pond
so we can push it and now again we're
threatening a3 a3 would come with tempo
so that's the that's the move we're
trying to play here so white again has
to to make a move to get out of the way
so now if a3 we can just take the pawn
on b3 Bishop a3 there's nothing
particularly wrong but in general just
when you're attacking the black king
this is where where you'll always find
the bishop in these these lines it's
just a very useful attacker because
eventually these pawns are going to move
out of the way
you know whenever this let's say let's
let's put them on a anyone for a second
at some moment you know when you have
pawns here you'll be able to play the
move d5 and then unleash this bishop and
you're going to play there's going to be
a lot of tricks usually on the g7 square
you also have a queen that can easily
come in and attack g7 so you typically
keep it on the long diagonal because
white is playing for checkmate if you
don't you know you don't checkmate them
then they're going to win kind of in the
endgame because they're their passers
will be strong so okay so I was a great
question
you're very welcome okay so he keeps his
Bishop on the long diagonal and now a
novelty so this was kind of an excellent
move it allows a lot of complications so
I don't know if it Carl prepared this or
if he you know just figured this out
over the board probably he was ready for
this because he played this move that
this going to allow for a lot of
complications but now we have two pieces
that are eyeballing the bishop so we're
trying to play our dream move Knight to
c5 which okay it's it's hard to stop but
things are about to get complicated
white plays efore so okay things are
things are getting tricky he's about to
play e5 so if you move your knight or
queen you're obviously going to feel
silly that you just played the move you
know Queen to d6
so you have to play the move Knight to
c5 allowing the pin or allowing the fork
sorry so now things are complicated
we're going to poach it a husha black
get out of this obviously we need to
move our Queen first she's attached
that's the most important thing in this
position so where's the Queen going to
go here why did we just get forked and
wire ball everybody's attacked all of
your Knights are attacked the Queen
right so yeah Queen c6 with the idea
that now you'll you'll be able to snap
off the bishop because the the Queen is
stuck defending the Jeep on so in the
game he took on f6 which is probably the
most critical if you take on c5 which
has its appeal there's two good moves
possibly the objectively best move is to
play rook takes d3 and allow these these
complications but it's it's almost the
easier way to play is just to play the
move Knight to g4 with the point then it
is kind of a funny point you can't stop
me from sacrificing
my my rope here for your bishop so if
you play a move like this we take the
bishop and okay when you take back we'll
take here and will trade a lot of stuff
and now it's is becoming clear we're
going to have a very easy plan of
blockading these ponds and our ponds are
coming quick you know we're going to
some defend our pond you know we might
put our Bishop here actually and then
we'll just we'll push and push and but
you know we'll start pushing our ponds
so it'd be very unpleasant for white so
in the game eat-eat xf6 was played so
okay
now we get to snatch off the the bishop
so again we can't take the knight unless
we want to blend our checkmate
alright so we got this piece back and
the game gets complicated even further
after the move Queen to g4 threatening
checkmate and provoking the move g6
because now a common theme is going to
be does black or just white have some
way of sneaking the Queen in for a
lollies mate
will it be possible okay so this will be
a theme that black needs to be aware of
because if your Queen doesn't have a way
to get back either to take this pawn or
to get back to f8 to defend you can get
into to some trouble here okay so for
now white blocks the connection between
the Queen and the bishop and the jeep on
so perhaps now the Queen is thinking of
sneaking in of infiltrating into the
black King side here so alright a nice
move nice interference by by akaru
and these are the kinds of tactical
things that you're trying to make work
you're trying to push your pawns so when
you can you should if white takes he
didn't in the game black would be able
to take and now he can push and after he
he takes here you're going to run into a
lot of trouble so I mean this just looks
very very pleasant for black so that
wasn't played the said Queen g5 right
we're getting we're getting closer and
he takes he makes a queen so I'd like to
ask the audience if white were to play
the move
if Queen to h6 threatening checkmate
what would black play here okay what is
it
right excellent
Queen takes d4 it says this other check
and then you're either going to
checkmate white or you're going to be
able to take the f6 pawn which would end
all of your trouble yeah it looks pretty
bad for him
no bad things are about to happen so
with this many Queens so black would
just just win here okay so it doesn't
work yet so he had to take the Queen all
right so now black has to find some way
of defending he has to be able to get
back to stop the the checkmating threats
so he plays Queen to b6 okay simply I
want to take this if you play the move
c5 will just play something like Queen B
- and you're going to realize you have
you have some troubles because again
we're just threatening this pawn so you
could like take here is probably the
best move and then you're going to
realize you're in a lotta a lot of
trouble I can defend so well I can avoid
the the checkmate a different way this
time I can use the rook C yeah so it was
pointed out that for this continuation
White has a really nice threat here he
can take on h7 so checkmate so let's get
will get get to the bottom of this
variation so we'll get to the bottom of
it should be fine I'll mess up the
screen for the people at home okay so
this was correct this was correct so far
we're doing great and King goes this way
King f8 that's the move that you got to
play yeah what's the problem
yep run away yep no problems no problems
yeah all right no no problems all right
so that would win
alright okay so we figured it out yeah
yeah you just you just run away okay
mm-hmm so yeah so c5 is is out of the
question
so let's we'll see what he played he
took the the night okay so that that
defends the D pawn at least once so the
Queen won't take it but the route can
take it all right so right so now if you
play here this move is going to come
with with check which is going to be bad
news
so what white played here was rook b1
kind of an interesting move so now he's
he's saying all right when you're Queen
moves if you made some legal move you
might drop your rook so he's kind of the
most important guy so you need to
protect him okay so he takes the bishop
and black wins a little bit more
material now sometimes white will have
this threat threat if it can work
sometimes he has this sacrifice in the
position he still has these ideas but if
if we can meet it with Queen FA it will
be perfectly safe for now the knight is
attacked so the knight moved away and
now black continues to play some pretty
good moves you push the pawn so the pawn
is just two squares away from queening
and white has no threats of checkmate so
white plays a very practical move he
takes on f7 now you can take the rook
and you'll survive but it's
understandable why since you're winning
even if you don't take the rook you
don't want to allow these sorts of ideas
and you know so it's a very practical
decision to not take the rook because
he'll he'll take it a little bit later
first he gave this cheque on b6 gave
another check and now he played a the
most practical move in the position he
took the night with check you don't have
to but okay now white resigned because
without the threat of 95
black is going to be able to safely take
the rook on the next move and then okay
the games can be over you're down way
too much against a player like Hikaru
so so that was one way to play against
the the knight to d2 line this is a game
Gris Chuck has the the black pieces here
and he's done quite a lot for that the
theory of this opening he's come up with
a lot of good ideas so if you're trying
to learn the no bloom it's a good idea
to watch some of his games they're very
instructive he really understands how to
play these positions as black so alright
so we will reach our position once more
with both sides ready and now we'll play
the main main main line which is rook to
e1 so in the past moves you know like
just rook to e8 have been pretty popular
Queen to c7 is actually known to be a
slight mistake here which is important
to know black almost always puts the the
Queen on c7 we saw it in on the other
two lines but it's a little bit
different here just because this rook
will at some point come over to the c1
square for example if we we play the
movie 4 which seems like the most
natural and they play e5 again we can't
push or take without giving up the c5
square so you play C 5 and now you
instead of capturing right away which
which is ok white can play a move like
this which will kind of demonstrate the
difference without the Queen on c2 now
this is a really really big threat for
example if you pass this will Wilfork
your pieces you can't really take what
will take here with the night and we're
going to win a piece so yes you don't
want to play a Queen c7 in these lines
with with rook e1 which is that's one
important thing to know so the most
common move at least nowadays rook to e8
is another move that used to be the most
popular move but uh okay
the most common move is Knight to e4
you're preventing light from playing the
move he wants to play and now the game
will have a slightly different feel to
it because after what
well white will soon provoke a move like
like f5 and then suddenly maybe it's
going to be black that's going to be
wanting to play on the Kings side so
we're going to have a slightly slightly
different feel here
okay so c5 so once again we want to go
here and blockade along the light
squares so very common whenever the move
c5 is played black responds with Bishop
c6 taking away the b5 Square from the
other bishop okay
so white provokes a weakness you should
you have to to support your knight here
so you have to play a move like like
Knight f5 if if you play a move like
this you're going to get into a lot of
trouble after a move like 95 we're
attacking your Bishop and then in the
future I'm going to play f3 and your
Knights going to have to go to you know
some silly square you can you can go
lose a pawn or you can go back to g5 and
be really be really sad so you have to
defend with your F pawn now that uh this
weakness has been created Y can go ahead
and begin to target it and now a very
interesting decision actually so he
played what seems like the most normal
move right you'd get your Queen and you
defend the pawn but it is also possible
to play the move Knight Queen to e8
which is kind of seems kind of strange
because it doesn't let your rook get out
at least to the center but your rook is
is quite good on f8 and the Queen does a
lot on this square that she's not doing
when she's on e7 so she's defending the
pawn she's you know defending the a
Foursquare and she might swing over to
the Kings side if ever black launches an
assault so okay so this is one possible
move order that is an interesting idea
so here's the game and one thing that
didn't happen but it's kind of
instructive is what happens if white
plays the move Queen to b3 we're going
to see a very typical sacrifice and
black can play a very cute move here
King h8 now the pawn is untouchable
what will black play if white is to take
this pawn black now has a really good
move
and if you play the note bloom a lot
this is a sacrifice you're going to see
over and over again so yeah so yeah we
can we can take on c5
alright giving up the knight will take
back with with another Knight and now we
have a fork of the the queen and the
bishop so we're going to be up upon and
it's going to be a good one
so okay you can try to play a move like
Queen c2 maybe but uh all right I'll
attack your Queen and when you when you
move I'll be able to take this guy so
blacks up a pawn and now you have
absolutely no attack on the Kings side
and and these guys are ready to be
pushed already so okay in the game
Bishop b3 was played white again intends
to to blockade with a move like you know
Bishop a4 at some point here okay he
plays King h8 anyway cuz just in general
you don't want to have your your King on
the same line here as the bishop so he
just gets out of the way and you can't
play it yet but maybe at some point if
you can get to move like a five in to
get rid of the weakness without allowing
white to be able to play d5 he's now
ready to do that okay so white plays the
move rook to d1 which is okay he can
think about just immediately playing
Bishop to a4 but okay and now the Queen
goes to e8 so the Queen could have
already been on e85 for the the blockade
here he takes and now an important
decision but it's a very common one
should you take back with the rook or
the Queen now if you if you played these
variations before you'll know you almost
always take back with the rook because
you're not intending to trade Queens
you're never intending to to make this
this trade if you're white you're the
one that's playing for checkmate so
that's one reason you might want to keep
the Queens on the board but also there's
going to be situations where you know
you're here and your opponent is
bringing in like
works for defense and when you have more
major pieces that are attacking the pawn
your pieces are going to be a lot better
they're the ones that are you know
blockading and attacking the pawn and
the other black pieces will be
blockading so you want to have as many
pieces on the board so you can end up
with a lot more better pieces than than
your opponent okay so the knight comes
in so we have an attack on the pawn so
black must defend all right and now
black is going to play a very very
interesting move all right
it's complicated already so it's it's
Knight to g4
so it's okay we're going to we're going
to have some complications it seems like
oh I'm just taking this and when you
take back I'm taking this but uh okay
we're going to see it's a lot more more
complicated than that but uh this is
actually an unfortunate move even though
it might be your best why it actually
has a very hard to see move here so I'll
get rid of these arrows so you can you
can think about it it's not Knight takes
g4 but I'll give you a chance in for the
class to see can you find a really
really nice move for white you know it's
not going to be some some brilliant
thing but it's one when you see it
you'll start to realize it's a very good
move so this is tricky so I'll see I'll
see what the class comes up with yeah
excellent yeah so Queen to d3 is a the
move for choice here so okay if you
trade Queens and it's it's hard not to I
mean if you if you don't okay if threes
coming so if you trade Queens and we
take back well now we're we're ready to
play f3 we're also ready to play Knight
takes before we're ready to play rook
takes a five so you would have to go
back and then your your Queen side is
going to fall apart rather quickly here
okay
so right you can start you can you can
take either pond and then when those
pawns you know go just disappear you're
going to be in a lot of trouble black
still has all of his pawns in the center
and he's going to have a lot of fun but
that move was missed and instead the
knight took on g4 and now things
are still you know not very good for
black-white is still a lot better here
but it's better than in the game and
this is interesting so why did why do
you just give up his night what does
black have to play here how's he going
to regain his his piece because he gave
a piece away what's going on Queen e2
attacking the bishop and f2 so you're
threatening checkmate so we'll make a
really bad move to to illustrate it now
we would take the pawn and okay we're
gonna have a back rank checkmate so okay
so that that's blacks point behind his
play so he's going to get the pawn back
or he's gonna get the piece back sorry
so White has to defend and now okay
so white gets a choice of which pawn he
wants to pick up here he takes the one
in the center now you have three passed
pawns here so if you can you know hold
on here a little bit and you should be
able to White will be the one that's
starting to move his pawns up the board
all right so b3 was played when you push
these pawns are they going to become
weak or they can become strong is it
going to make it what can afford to take
this pawn though it's understandable why
you might be scared in the game you know
a move like this is coming and black
just intends to to bring this this pawn
down to Victory Lane but you can play
the move Queen to d1 I always play Queen
d1 it does allow a small tactic but it's
still good for white it allows this move
rook takes f2 with the point okay you
take the rook I take your queen you take
my queen I take your rook and then I
take your queen so okay you could take
and then either recaptures is going to
be slightly better for white you can
capture this way and now we have a
little tactic we can take here okay so
the point is you can't take because
there'll be a background check mate
you'll move somewhere and you know we'll
be able to round up this pawn okay and
it should be slightly better for for
white at least for
the moment you're not threatening to win
the e pawn because of the the back rank
checkmate and if why it really really
feels it's necessary he can play moves
like this and just yeah get rid of one
of the rooks so okay also possible is
taking with the the pawn sorry yeah
after what are you saying uh-huh
yeah okay so yes it's a little bit more
complicated right so this was mentioned
by the incredibly intelligent audience
okay and then right so then you you get
your Queen not good for white so we
can't take the rook all right we can all
right we can bring the probably number
either working we can go here okay
and it should be should be good okay we
can start we can both start pushing our
ponds you again we can trade it first I
don't know but it's you can keep your
rook on the board that's probably the
best actually and okay you'll get some
interesting position white should be a
little bit better I'm just saying it's
going to be really complicated so still
anything can happen
all right but he didn't take the Jeep on
he you know tried to go to c4 to prevent
a move like Queen to c2 getting out of
the way the b-pawn it also is kind of
funny or your queen is a little bit
trapped in there
so okay alright so he wants to to trade
the Queens and then he's going to try to
demonstrate that this pawn is actually
quite weak he can go and attack it so
black tries to keep the Queens on the
board
and now white makes a big mistake you
should probably just play a move like
Queen c4 and you know basically say you
have to trade Queens if you play here
you're getting in the way of your pond
again and if you play here we're just
going to take and now this pawn is going
to be much easier to to pick up in this
variation okay
but that wasn't played white played a
the losing move c6 which might not be
obvious
immediately why this this move is so bad
but but actually now white is completely
lost
okay b2 is an easy move to find you're
right you know you're just one square
away alright so he would like to trade
Queens so black can't can't allow that
because if you trade Queens then this
guy will be weak so he keeps the Queens
on the board and there's going to be a
lot of tricks with taking the f2 pawn so
like rook takes f2 these these kind of
tricks are going to pop into the
position so he could already do it
because if you know you're up takes we
can always make a queen all right so he
threatens to make a queen himself
so obviously don't have time to to play
a move like this because uh he Queens
first and we get background check mated
so he prevents it and now okay slightly
better is a queen to b5 but in either
case he's he's lost we can double so
we're really threatening to take on f2
there's not a lot you can do about it
always play Queen d1 but here it's a
little bit too late now the sacrifice
just works and it's game over
so here the player with white resigned
it's just hopeless it's it's matin three
so so that's one way to play when you
play the the main main main line which I
thought was an excellent model game it
showed a lot of the typical tactics and
strategies that you can play so
hopefully that gives you a good overview
of the note bloom maybe you want to try
it out in some of your games so let me
know how that goes in the comments below
and if you have any suggestions go ahead
and tell me so maybe I'll feature your
your favorite opening on on YouTube um
yeah so like me subscribe give me a
thumbs up give me a hug blow me kisses
and all the other internet stuff
I'm Jonathan Krantz thanks a lot